okay you [ __ ] [ __ ] we're doing
Shep to 6d island [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] danger crocodile no swim but
luckily as a box here both inside a
Chelsea ma Lampert this is his house so
we're gone to the top Chavez house how
do you manage to get through the future
okay bloody about no problem
can I scoop out the water yeah it is the
monarch out luckily I can got to that
path it's out of power
great all right good good anything in
the ambulance any cement in here I can't
go jack a pump attach a sphincter
[Music]
okay well let's here's the enema pump at
the motor
[Music]
that's just a jacket this
oh man what's going on here missed our
mailbox or anything in here
[Music]
Oh fuel cat have a bay
[Music]
mr. Lambert
I don't like how he stopped like that so
annoying
okay let's get out of here
let's get when I was wait so he's about
to get the house look a coffee up
cracking house
racket ass
let's blow this burg [ __ ] yeah got all
garden chairs would be a shame ground
pots
oh great mr. crocodile kill him
yeah pull them in their house not cracks
in here
hmm yeah I guess I have to go back
mr. sundial there's a good freakin clown
fish right there
luck I uh smile kay let's shock this
fish get him get him
can't supply
get this fish cook the fish give it to
the croc okay I guess I'm just giving
the raw fish I guess you've really no
point to cooking it get out of here
let's get out of here this is a pretty
easy game hey patch yeah freakin
chainsaw don't mind if I do
and guess who's locked okay so I
probably ought to fill this up with
moonshine moonshine tamping I love
touching my body oh baby love touching
my body with moonshine well no it works
it's so slow why does she still like
prison guards on her janitor combat by
you get that